richard writer AKA nova is finally
making his way to the MCU and fans are
super excited about it especially
considering the fact that he was
supposed to make his MCU debut in
guardians of the galaxy vol 1 and he was
also supposed to be in Avengers infinity
war and possibly Avengers in game after
that as well but he is finally coming
how's it going everybody it's Lawren and
awesome news today Nova is finally
coming to the MCU we expected this
because the president of Marvel Studios
Kevin Feige had talked about Nova being
a priority for the MCU only a couple of
years ago in 2017 but what does his
return mean and could it possibly bring
back to the big screen an old favorite
villain of ours
Thanos we'll talk about it in this video
quick reminder to subscribe comment and
like the video if you'd like to enter my
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox one
or a ps4 and so you can stay up to date
on everything relating to the MCU so
Nova is headed to the MCU and this has
been reported by comic book calm and MCU
cosmic calm as well and this is
something comic-book comm reported two
years ago in 2017 Kevin Feige the
president of Marvel Studios told comic
book calm this Nova is if we have a big
board with a bunch of characters that
have more immediate potential Nova is on
that board because of the connection to
the guardians universe because there are
more than one examples to pull from in
the comics that are interesting and
you're absolutely right he was in the
earliest drafts of the guardians of the
galaxy so two years ago Kevin Feige said
that Nova was a priority to get into the
MCU and he was supposed to be in the
first guardians of the galaxy and he was
even supposed to be in Avengers infinity
war the writers for Avengers infinity
war and Avengers endgame have revealed
that the beginning of Infinity Ward did
not start with Thor and Fanus not in the
earliest drafts of the movie instead it
started with the destruction of Xander
home of the Nova Corps and Nova in this
scene all of the Nova Corps would have
been destroyed except for one person
Richard Reiter and then he would have
inherited all of the Nova force and
instead of the Hulk being sent to earth
to warn the Avengers it was actually
Nova who went to earth and warn them
about Thanos but ultimately and sadly
that scene never made the final cut
however since now Nova is headed to the
MCU the most likely scenario in which he
arrives in the MCU is most likely the
guardians of the galaxy
again Kevin Feige said he shared a
connection to the Guardians and he was
supposed to be in the first Guardians
movie and sadly not too many people know
who Nova is outside of our fandom so it
would make sense that they introduced
him in another film first and then give
him his own solo film but with the
introduction of Noah to the MCU comes
his backstory and what is his backstory
well we already know it it's exactly the
scene that I mentioned was supposed to
happen in Avengers infinity war now we
know from Thor that Thanos decimated
Xander and then we learned from the
writers that only one person in the Nova
Corps survived
Richard Rider so what happened to him
well that's where he comes into the MCU
as you know the guardians of the galaxy
especially star-lord have a very deep
connection to Xander and if you notice
in Avengers infinity war where Thor
tells the Guardians that Xander was
decimated you can see how troubled
star-lords face looks so in guardians of
the galaxy vol 3 you can definitely
expect that they'll make a stop
byes and are just to see the destruction
and if this does happen and they decide
to introduce Nova in Guardians 3 this is
definitely where they will find Nova and
when they introduce Nova to the MCU
they're going to have to go over his
backstory and how he became Nova
specifically how Richard Rider became
Nova now in the comics Richard Rider is
a teenager who lives on earth he is
selected by the last remaining member of
the Nova Corps rom and day to receive
the Nova Force now this is how it
happens in the comics but it's not going
to go down this way in the MCU because
the writers of infinity war and endgame
already have revealed how it goes down
Richard Reiter is of Xander and he is
the last remaining member of the Nova
Corps this means that he has all of the
Nova force bestowed upon him and this
means that he fought Thanos and as he
goes over his backstory and house and
art got destroyed we could see this
scene play out which means we could see
fan OHS on the big screen once again
Thanos is such a huge villain and
although it took years to build him up
many fans are disappointed that he is
already gone and although there are many
different ways that they knows could be
revived and returned to the MCU we will
most likely see him return to the big
screen when Nova is introduced into the
MCU we could finally get this scene the
destruction of Xander Richard rather
becoming Nova inheriting all of the Nova
force and him going up against and
trying to stop fan oohs the mad Titan
from getting the Power Stone ultimate
we know he fails because Thanos does in
fact retrieve the power stone but this
is most likely where guardians of the
galaxy 3 will pick up there is no
guarantee that it will be guardians 3
but it will be a cosmic movie so that
only leaves a few options guardians 3
which already has a connection to Nova
and Captain Marvel too but if it is
guardians 3 that means we could see Nova
in the MCU as early on as 2022 so
exciting news Nova is coming in with his
introduction we could possibly see that
destruction of xander scene finally so
it's probably not the last time you've
seen Thanos on the big screen so what
are your thoughts on this would you like
to see this destruction of z' and our
scene and what movie do you think that
Nova will be introduced in drop your
answer in the comments down below give
the video a like if you enjoyed it and
of course don't forget to subscribe to
my channel so you can stay up to date on
all things relating to the MCU and so
you can enter my giveaway for your
chance to win an Xbox one or a ps4 don't
forget to follow me on Twitter and
Instagram I do giveaways on there as
well and as always thank you all so much
for watching
woof woof